il ya un accessoire de mode qui est
hyper sexy c'est les chaussettes
faux je ne peux pas te laisser dire ça à
l'âne tu as tout faux
les chaussettes c'est ce qu'il ya de
moins sexy au monde je sais steven
c'était de l'ironie
mais bien sûr tu me fais honte alan tu
ne connais rien sur rien tu n'es
vraiment pas digne de reprendre la
société de papa alors là je peux te dire
que j'en connais un rayon sur les
chaussettes alors ne me cherche pas très
bien le premier qu'il en a plus rien à
dire de pertinent sur les chaussettes ne
reprendra pas la société de papa défi
relevé tu me fait pas peur steven hélas
à peine plus
[Musique]
je prends la main je t'en prie quel
idiot il n'ya qu'une seule chose à dire
sur les chaussettes en prenant la main
je gagne forcément tu as remarqué que
c'est toujours la fois où on met une
paire de chaussettes trouées que comme
par hasard on se retrouve dans une
soirée où il faut retirer ses chaussures
bien observer il est foutu un truc
marrant avec les chaussettes
1 c'est qu'elles contiennent quatre
tailles en une par exemple 39 à 42 ou 43
à 46 on ne verra jamais un t-shirt high
tech à ixelles game over alan je ne
comprends pas de quoi tu parles tu viens
de faire une croix sur la société de
papa tu ne comprends pas de quoi je
parle rassure moi tu ne dis pas ça car
tu n'as plus rien a dit comment est il
du vide et non c'est faux je suis encore
plein de trucs en stock
je t'écoute qu'est qu'il est le plus
bizarre entre porter des chaussettes de
sport quand on ne fait pas de porte
il portait des chaussettes de ville
quand on vit à la campagne
bonne question tiens j'ai eu très très
chaud mais là il est cuite ce qui est
marrant aussi avec les chaussettes non
c'est impossible il n'y a plus rien à dr
c'est ce phénomène inexplicable de la
chaussette qui disparaît quand on fait
une machine aaa n'est pas du tout
pertinent à l'âme
tu penses que cette expérience est
universel mais elle ne l'est pas c'est
vrai steven et que toi qui perd une de
deux chaussettes moi même nom mais
jamais perdu qu'une seule fois j'étais
persuadé que ça arriver à tout le monde
la partie est terminée alors ceci est
faux personne et oui en tant que proches
incontesté de cette famille je me dois
de rétablir la vérité si venait bel et
bien le seul à n'avoir jamais perdu de
chaussettes
mais il ya une raison à cela il n'en a
jamais porté et ce depuis le début c'est
vrai nom on lit le mans n'a jamais
remarqué qu'il était tout le temps pieds
nus mais oui c'est pour ça que je n'ai
jamais vu tu les as un chantier tout
s'explique
[Musique]
qui de alan de steven reprendre à
l'entreprise familiale
vous le saurez pas dans cet épisode
fairy
ce qui est marrant quand on s'abonne à
la chaîne multiprise c'est qu'on est sûr
de ne rater aucune des vidéos c'est
hyper pratique faux non c'est vrai t'as
raison
j'adore te contredire mais là j'avoue
que c'est le truc le plus vrai que tu
aies jamais dit de toute ta vie vraie
niktamère alan hahn